الان الى تطورت من في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث افادت مراسله الجزيره
باستمرار تبادل القصف بين القوه
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه والمواليه لها
في عدد من محاور القتال في شرق اوكرانيا
قالت السلطات المحليه المواليه لروسيا في
دنياز من القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت عددا من
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها في المقاطعه
باكثر من 160 قذيفه مدفعيه وصواريخ جراند
الاوكرانيه عن صدق قواتها سته محاولات
تقدم من القوات الروسيه في مقاطعه
الشرقيه شكرا
فقدت قياده المنطقه الشرقيه في الجيش
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه احرزت تقدما
بسيطه في جبهه باخمود شمال مقاطعه
واكد الجيش الاوكراني اصابه اكثر من 750
جنديا روسيا خلال معارك الاسبوع الماضي
شرقي البلاد
15 اخرون في قصف روسي استهدف مدن وبلدان
في المقاطعه
على الاسلحه في الخارجيه الروسيه
من ان الاقمار الصناعيه شبه المدنيه
المستخدمه في اوكرانيا
للقوات الروسيه
الفضائيه المدنيه وفي مقدمتها مجموعه من
الاقمار الصناعيه المدارس
تحركات واعمال القوات الروسيه والتحكم
بالمسيرات وكذلك توجها الاسلحه الموجهه
بدقه
لاستخدام الاستفزازيه للاقمار الصناعيه
المدنيه يثير تساؤلات في سياق معاهده
الفضاء الخارجي والتي تعني استخدامها
سلميه فقط ويتطلب اشد الا ده من قبل
المجتمع الدولي
كل هذه التطورات وما بعدها مع مراسلنا من
اكرامتوس كعامر لاثي ومن دونيت سلام خضر
اهلا بكم من جديد فكره موتورز قوى محيطها
عامر ما اخر تطورات الميدانيه
رئيس المسكي وصف الجبهه هنا ودعيني ابدا
بهذا الوصف لانه معبر قال بان تبقى الجبهه
في الشرق هي الاصعب جبهه صعبه ملتهبه وهذا
هو تعبيره وهي كذلك بالفعل بعد نعم تحدث
طبعا عن انه ما زالت القوات الاوكرانيه
تصد كل هذه الهجمات الروسيه على هذه
المنطقه وتمنع قوات روسيه من السيطره على
مناطق في لوغانس وفيدو ناس وقال بانه طبعا
كانت روسيا قد وعدت بالسيطره على دونيس في
الربيع القادم ثم الصيف ثم الخريف وقال
باننا نحن الان قد بدا فصل الشتاء ولم
يحققوا اهدافهم وانهم يتكبدون الكثير من
الخساره قبل قليل ذكرتهم في النشره ان
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه بالفعل كانت قد
اعلنت عندنا 720 جارحه الروسيه قد نقلوا
الى مستشفيات العاصمه عاصمه انفصاليه في
دونيس خلال فقط الاسبوع الماضي تحدثت ايضا
قياده الاركان بالمناسبه عن ان العديد من
المستشفيات
المدنيه قد تم تحويلها الى مستشفيات
عسكريه واعطت مثالا اليوم على مستشفى في
هيرليفكا بانه تم تحويلها الى عسكريه ومنع
المدنيون من دخول هذه المستشفى هذا لماذا
بسبب العدد الكبير من الاصابات هناك لكن
على الجبهه طبعا تستمر محاولات تقدم من
جانب القوات الروسيه ست محاولات تمكنت
القوات الاوكرانيه من صدها وفقا لقياده
الاركان تبقى الاجابهات الاصعب ربما هي في
دونيس وتحديدا في اربع مناطق في سبيلر
وبخمود في الشمال وفي افديك واوليدار في
الجنوب لكن تبقى جبهه مخمود طبعا هي
الاصعب ربما من بين كل هذه الجبهات اليوم
اعترفت قياده المنطقه الشرقيه العسكريه
الاوكرانيه بان هناك التقدما وصفاته
بالطيف او البسيط احرزته القوات الروسيه
في هذا المحور نعمل لقناه الروسيه قالت
بان سيطرت على قرى همم في الجنوب والجنوب
الشرقي اندرو يبقى كوردي ما يفكا وفقا
لمصادر تحدثنا معها طبعا قدر اتكلم تتحدث
عن هذه المواضيع ابدا لكن مصادرنا التي
تحدثنا معها قالوا بان هناك انسحاب للقوات
الاوكرانيه من اندرو يفكى لكنهم نفو تماما
ان تكون القوات الروسيه قدسيطرت على
كورديو ما يفكا وهي منطقه في الجنوب
الغربي همم محمود والسيطر عليها ربما قد
تعطي اولويه او حقيقيه للجيش الروسي
لمحاصره هذه المدينه التي اقتربت اقتربوا
منها كثيرا طبعا وتؤكد هذه المصادر بان
عدد كبير من القوات الروسيه يقتل يوميا
على هذا المحور لكن بسبب التعزيزات التي
تصل بشكل مستمر وخصوصا تلك التي اتت من
الجنوب من خرسان فهم ما زالوا قادرين على
شم الهجمات على هذا المحور محمود نفس
الشيء ايضا في ارض يبقى مريم همم الحديث
عن تقدم ايضا هناك لكن القوات الروسيه
الاوكرانيه تنفيذ ذلك وايضا في هو اللي
دار التي قال لنا المصادر بانهم ادعوا
اكثر من 10 مرات انهم سيطروا عليها وهم
يدعون الان وهو تلك المصادر العسكريه
حيث انت
عبد الناصر نبدا من التطورات الميدانيه
السلطات سلطات المواليه لروسيا تقول انها
حقق التقدما في ثلاث مناطق جنوب باخمود
وتقول ان هذا التقدم مستمر بحسب السلطات
المحليه
والهدف من هذا التقدم بحسب ال- همم
السلطات هنا هو قطع الامداد المباشر او
الاتصال المباشر بين منطقه باخبط وبين
منطقه افديتك بينما القتال لا يزال مستمر
عند محور اجليدار السلطات هنا تقول ان
القتال مستمر ولم يتم الدخول الى منطقه
اغنيدار ولكن هناك تطور اخر في منطقه
ذاكولوجيا يجب الاشاره اليها عبد الصمد
قبل قليل نقلت وكاله فيزا عن متحدث باسم
شركه
يقول هذا المتحدث بان قصف القوات
الاوكرانيه استهدف منشات تخزين النفايات
النوويه في مح براجيا للطاقه النوويه لكنه
اكد ان الحاويات نفسها لم تتاثر الرجل
اصدر تحذيرا يقول بان استمرار القصف
الاوكراني على همم
محطه زابروجيه من شانه ان يرفع من
احتماليات او اي يبقي احتمال وقوع حادث
النووي خطير امرا قائما وهو قال بذلك فان
السلطات الاوكرانيه تضع او تحول الدول
المجاوره الى
رهاء بحسب تعبيره في الاثناء القتال جنوب
دانياتك لا يزال مستمرا وكذلك القصف
المتبادل بين الطرفين رصدنا همم
عمل المضادات الجويه لمرتين ليله امس وفي
ساعات الصباح الاولى يبدو انها كانت تتصدى
لاهداف جويه ولكن تنتظر اعلان الرسميا
بذلك نشير اخيرا الى ان شرق دمياط احدى
المناطق الواقعه شرق مدينه تعرضت لقصف
صحيح وقالت السلطات ان
المناطق الاستهداف قصفت بصواريخ هاي مارس
عبد الصمد
ايضا مراسله جزيره عامر لافي وكان معنا من
كرامته